give me the ball
alligator take the stroke and move on or
drop a new ball somewhere else a gator
can close its jaws faster than you can
react to it my name is Frank Rob I have
called alligators for the State of
Florida through their nuisance alligator
program for going on 29 years now today
we're going to look at alligator and
crocodile attacks and TV and movies and
judge how real they
are their site underwater is is Prett
good it's not as good as it is above
water but it's good enough where if they
want to find you they're going to find
you that is how they lay in the water
they they'll lay just kind of chilled
out with their arms hanging out from
both sides and the tail kind of back
there they could sense something below
them moving around and not be looking at
it you could be Michael Phelps in your
Prime and you're not going to out swim
in alligator it just ain't going to
happen they swim faster underwat than
they do Above Water by quite a ways they
can swim up to you know probably about
20 something miles per hour they can
they can get going pretty
quick I've heard so many arguments over
the years about how to get away from an
alligator safely you're running zigzags
or you know you're run a straight line
they're not going to chase you it's not
not something they're going to do but if
you're trying to get away from one you
just make yourself big you make some
noise and back away Gators in homes are
very common now chasing you around under
your home or in your home or chasing you
around anywhere outside your home that's
not realistic the last one I got at
somebody's house and this was during a
hurricane and whenever she turned around
to go back in her house here was this
alligator that had walked in was on top
of a shelf in her bedroom trying to get
out the bedroom window trying to escape
he wanted nothing to do with her he was
trying to get away the last thing they
want to do is have an interaction with
you I would rate these clips from crawl
on a scale from 1 to 10 with a very
solid one for Coral I actually did the
safety tips that came out with the
DVD holy spirit is so bad whoever worked
on the Anatomy on this had it spot on I
mean they have the things the isos
around his mouth they're sensory organs
so alligators have those they look like
little dots around their face on
crocodiles they have those little dots
or these sensory organs which are like
underwater radar or sonar their eyesight
is on par with any bird prey I mean they
have very very good eyesight and they
have something we call a nickota
membrane which will fold over their eyes
it's a second eyelid it's like it's
their underwater goggles
Che they would pick you up from
underwater and pull you down and there
would be no him looking at you
beforehand he's not going to let you
know he's there he's just going to pick
you up and take
you a crocodile that size yes could bite
through pretty much whatever he wants
people look at him via drone sometimes
and they get their drones eaten quite
often people get too close to the animal
it's almost like they're harassing it
and they'll get tired of it cuz they'll
they'll pick a bird up they'll just
reach up there and grab it and pull it
[Music]
down that firearm with an animal that
size is not going to make a whole lot of
difference they have these things in
their back called osteoderms it's a
solid piece of their back this is how
they Thermo regulate each one of these
are connected together to make a big
piece of armor and their blood
circulates through this is how they get
warm or cold uh a bullet hitting one of
these on an animal that size would make
no difference again you imagine an
animal that size would have a a tooth
probably the size of your hand they bite
each other and it's a lot worse than any
bullet could ever
[Music]
be those would not be two things you'd
find in the same area by any means but
if you have a crocodile who is as big as
that one's supposed to be if there was a
bear in the area he was in and it was on
the shoreline if if he wanted a bear he
would have himself a bear or American
crocodile is a big fish eater they like
fish but they'll also eat small mammals
pretty much whatever they can get their
mouth on they're they're happy to have
people are not not one of those things
I'd give it a six give it a solid
six you wouldn't be holding a snare like
that with bait in it and hoping the
animal would come over to you and go
into the snare and take the bait while
you're holding it all it's not it's not
how that works while saltwater
crocodiles get a reputation for being
very aggressive if you have something
dead out there hanging out for him he
might he might need a minute to think
about it it's not going to not going to
be something that's going to happen
immediately what he's using there is a
cable snare it's something we use for
alligators and crocodiles both them
we're doing research uh the way it works
is you go you put this thing around an
animal's neck and it cinches shut and
you can pull the animal to you can catch
it it's not the way you would really
want to approach a saltwater crocodile
especially an animal of that size so if
we're dealing with alligators or
crocodiles uh we'll what we typically do
is we'll catch them on a fishing rod
then you can use a rope or a snare do
what you need to do with them and then
let them back loose there it's pretty
easy to let the snare
loose you would never want to attach it
to your boat just kind of ridiculous so
I mean no no part of the clip really
made any sense
big there's been instances where we've
had alligators bite people's boats those
are animals that have been fed and
they're associating these people who are
out in their boats fishing with the fish
they're bringing in because they like
hey here's an easy way to catch it catch
food I'll wait till this guy pulls a
fish in then I'll go over there and try
to grab it before he gets in his boat so
sometimes that kind of thing happens but
it's not typical by any means a
crocodile that size again historically
they got that big could take a boat down
for sure realistically there wouldn't be
a whole lot of reason for him to do that
this clip would be r a nice solid one
the way that it was handled from the
beginning no part of it was
realistic that's alligator a gring
alligators communicate by a series of
bellows growls hisses they do
communicate um for sure with each other
that way and it sounds a little bit
something like
this for sure an alligator can jump like
that and and grab something without a
doubt I mean if you have one cornered
somewhere where he can't get out of it
and he's trying to defend himself yeah
they're going to Lunge at you they're
going to jump at you and they're going
to snap at you but it's not the
situation they want to find themselves
in it's pretty realistic I'd say let's
give that a
eight this is supposed to be in India
and these they're showing American
alligators in India it would either be
the Indian gerial or the uh Sal water
crocodile you can find in some places in
India as well so they got the they got
the species
wrong they're not a communial eater
whatsoever those animals are used to
eating together alligators in the wild
you're not going to find sharing a meal
does not happen if they've got something
and they want to rip a piece of it off
that's how they'll they'll take their
prey and rip a piece off in order to
have that right then and
there alligators and crocodiles both
they can dig just about anything they
have something we call gastroliths in
their stomach they're eating bones if
they can digest bones then piece of
cloth is nothing I'd give that a two if
you factored in the way they were eating
together I mean you as soon as you saw
that you'd immediately know that is not
a wild situation that's somewhere in a
farm system or in a
[Music]
zoo it's very common that one will kind
of make his way through an area calmly
if he's just kind of motoring around if
they're going real fast somewhere
they're not going to do it on top of the
water they're going to be stealthy about
it and do it
underwater crocodiles are ridiculously
strong they're very powerful animal
there's no person on this planet that
can match strength with one there would
be no reason for him to go knock someone
off there that crocodile could have
easily reached that chandelier with no
problems whatsoever and you're looking
at a crocodile that's 15 plus feet long
yeah no you're not
[Music]
safe
there's a big misconception that their
mouth shuts very easily and stays shut
very easily with a little bit of
pressure that is not true they have a a
giant enormous amount of power in
opening their mouth as well we use tape
so we'll use electricians like could
call it electrical tape it's really
alligator tape we use that to wrap their
mouths up and we'll usually cover their
eyes at the same time cuz it makes them
a little bit more
relaxed I don't care if you're arold
Sports Egger your Prime you're not
getting away with doing that he'd fling
you off like a bug and it you'd be you'd
be lunched so quick I would give this a
one while it was a lot of fun it was not
realistic realistic looking animal not
realistic looking
[Music]
actions Gators in pools are a very
common thing traditionally it's because
of
one one bigger Gator Run the smaller one
out and put him in a pool to he's trying
to escape where he knows he has his own
little secret spot his own little
alligator Haven down there in Florida we
have we're surrounded by lot of salt
water alligators don't have salt
excretion glands like crocodiles do so
they have to be able to go from fresh
water body to fresh water body a lot of
times that's what it is they're when
they're moving it's an easy spot to drop
off and kind of chill out for a day and
recover that is realistic the alligator
would just kind of go whatever buddy
like yeah I'm chilling out man it's my
it's my relax day it's my spa day
they're going to be underwater most of
the time I'll usually kind of have a
have a conversation with them get them
to kind of kind of put their head
through a rope and catch them that way
I'd give that one a nine alligator being
in a pool very common thing him turning
and snapping at the guy when he was
seeing the pool that part about it was
kind of goofy cuz he's going to sink and
go
hide only takes one turn time feeding an
alligator or a crocodile for them to go
this is an easy way to make a living
just hanging around the people let them
throw me things and I can save all that
energy I would be using otherwise
they're not going to go after you so
they get very used to people you should
never be feeding wildlife in general
definitely not crocodilians because they
associate people with that food very
quickly and that's how terrible things
happen it's not necessarily you that are
might not be worried about it but the
next person to come up there might not
know that's a Fed
animal in the wild American crocodiles
are actually even more secretive and
ghostlike than the American alligator
they want nothing to do with you they're
very very secretive animal they would
not approach you the way these are
approaching here that have been fed as
soon as something hit the water they're
going to be looking at it like it's
food if you tried to run and jump across
crocodiles you'd only do it once it just
it doesn't work out so well for you if
you're raing it looking at the realistic
uh possibility of crocodiles and
alligators approaching you in an
alligator farm it's pretty realistic if
you're looking at the realistic ability
of running across crocodiles that's not
going to happen so you got to give that
one like probably a solid
[Applause]
seven Gators on golf courses are a very
common thing pretty much any golf course
you're on in Florida will have Gators in
it there are a lot of behaviors that
change completely when an alligator's on
a golf course they get fed a lot um the
ones that aren't getting fed or getting
used to people walking by them and
golfing around them and moving around
them all the time so they get it the
alligators get complacent the people get
complacent give me the ball
alligator take the stroke and move on or
drop a new ball somewhere else don't you
don't play those kind of games a gator
can close its jaws faster than you can
react to
[Music]
it there's this misconception about
alligator wrestling that's not a real
thing it's that's an entertainment thing
there's no type of reality involved in
that as my uncle always says you don't
temp the devil there's no reason to Temp
things like that I'd give it a one the
way the clip played out with him jumping
in the water after it and wrestling it
headbutting it and elbowing it you
wouldn't be coming back from
that he jumps up kind of from a from a
front and above it and just jumps on the
animal puts a knife through its skull
plate no part of that makes any sense
they can't they do have a blind spot
directly behind them but that's not how
this was approached their head is not a
weak spot at all and if you watch this
this clip he actually puts the knife
through the animal's skull plate which I
don't care if you're Wolverine you're
not putting you're not putting a knife
through that thing's skull plate that's
a super super thick bone and you a knife
is not going to go through for realism
that is another solid one there's been
so little turned out in the movie world
uh with crocodiles and it's it's crazy
when you're saying lake plet is the most
realistic one but so far it's where it's
at
[Applause]
in Florida where we're at I get
alligators out of coverts or water
structures all the time there's all
these water structures between
neighborhoods that is part of their
environment that's a place that they
spend a lot their time in it's a very
common thing if people realize how many
alligators were under their
neighborhoods it would probably freak
them out as
well I've caught hundreds of alligators
out of situations exactly like that
where sometimes it's a 36 in pipe it's
sometimes a pipe you can duck walk
through and you uh you walk through
there and you you meet him and you have
a conversation with him he goes for a a
walk back out with
[Music]
you normally when you're cuz you're
usually crawling through you crawl hands
and knees on until you meet the animal
you get a rope on them and you pull them
back out I'll call the sheriff's office
or the fire department or call a couple
of friends and have them help me get him
back out the top they do act different
in different situations like you come
across an alligator in a cover pipe he's
going to stand his ground he's going to
say this is this is my spot my area you
turn around and go back I'm not going to
turn around and go back they're not
going to run away from you they're going
to stand on the ground you better start
backpedaling in a
[Music]
hurry I've never heard about a situation
where an alligator uses his tail to
knock somebody over when you're in the
middle of catching one um when you're
walking up behind them to get on them
they will sweep their tail back and
forth they try to keep you away from
them but they're not they're not out
there trying to knock you out with their
tail not the way it works it's strong
yeah it's strong for sure their tail
strong not something to be
overwhelmingly concerned about by any
means you want to worry about the sharp
end I'll give this one an eight because
it's an alligator and a covert pipe very
common
[Music]
thing they're most active at dawn and
Dusk and yeah at night time is usually
when they're walking out when they're
going out and feeding it's funny some of
the biggest alligators I've ever caught
were in the smallest water b as you
could ever imagine maybe in a couple
inches of water and kind of laying in
mud and you'd never know they were there
you put yourself
in it's not uncommon to see them in a
place like that as they're kind of
traveling through they're looking to
pick something up there are people that
uh go fishing and duck hunting and stuff
like that they will walk through an area
sometimes like that and step on one or
kick one and take a bite from that
usually it's a it's a mistake bite where
they'll turn around and bite something
and go who that was not something I was
looking to
bite having one roll you up and kill you
that's taken it a whole different step
past reality if there was deep water
nearby the animal is going to take you
and pull you to the deeper water it's
not necessarily going to be rolling
around with you pretty not realistic uh
just not things you need to worry about
but I I give it it I give it a two
because it is semi- possible my favorite
scenes I watch today were Lake Placid
and alligator Lake Placid uh just
because of how realistic looking that
animal was and then alligator there at
the very end the film alligator
alligators covert pipes if people had
any idea it would melt your
minds if you like this video why not
click on the next
one